the rise of the tamagotchi kids virtual
children that play with you cuddle you
and even look like you
will be commonplace in 50 years and
could help combat overpopulation
unbelievable ai expert predicts
if you read on in it says these
computer-generated offspring will only
exist in the immersive digital world
known as the metaverse
which is accessed using virtual reality
technologies such as a headset to make a
user feel as if they're face-to-face
with the child
and scrolling through that you can see
some imagery of there are some photos of
what that you know here's a mom
with virtual reality glasses on feeding
a digital baby
look the next one is a a woman
a mom look at the glasses i mean it's
it's so unbelievably black mirror
disturbing lifting up a small digital
child and
people look at this and i think to some
it's intriguing
i think to some it's funny and it's like
that's never going to happen oh it'll
happen it's coming it's absolutely
coming and i think others don't take a
second some are horrified like i am and
they're like this we need to how do we
what do we do what do we do to protect
kids what do we do to protect each other
from this mania and then some don't
really realize i think the full effects
of this i wrote a book a few years ago
called hashtag do not disturb
and it delves into
technology and how this new wave of
technology that's happening now not just
with social media but with these
metaverses i go into talking about a
video game
called second life i don't know if
you've ever heard of second life
it's pretty fascinating i write about it
in the book it's basically an alternate
universe a digital universe where you
can go into that universe and you can
get married you can
you can have a whole life you can have a
partner you can have intimacy
you can display intimacy on screen you
can own a business you can and there
were people who were spending hours and
hours all day
their whole day
with the exception of you know time that
they actually had to sleep in the real
world immersed in this digital world and
completely absent from real life so
there are people that never saw the
sunshine outside
who never you know didn't engage with
their friends
who were becoming overweight because
they were having no actual physical
activity in the great outdoors
deeply deeply disturbing stuff there
were people who were having affairs
in the game
and their spouses in real life their
partners in real life were learning
about it and confused and not
understanding what was happening this
stuff is incredibly destructive
incredibly destructive
and what it does
all of it by the way
is it tears at the fabric of what
connects us as people so that
interpersonal connection the touch
the eye contact all of that is necessary
to build you
and to build a community and to build a
sense of shared and common purpose and
to build a sense of oh i get where
you're coming from i don't agree
civility is built that way
all of those values that you come to
hold dear are built that way loyalty and
humanity and caring for your neighbor
that doesn't exist if you detach from
everyone and you exist in isolation in a
fake world that is meant to somehow
gratify you in ways that the real world
that's a little bit harder
it's a little bit harder in the real
world right because actually interacting
with people is harder
that real world doesn't make it so easy
so let's have a metaverse that makes it
easy let's have a metaverse in fact
where caring for your baby can just be
all all smiles and rainbows
let's do that
so what's happening here is you're not
building backbones in people you're not
building community between people
young kids are losing basic skills kids
don't even know how by the way to ask
each other out on a date anymore because
this is all they do
this
oh you want cowards it's a nation of
isolated detached cowards
cowards
it was hard in middle school
there were boys that came up to me in
middle school at the dance they had to
like
take that deep breath
they had to get there you know put their
clothes in order they had to you know
fist pump i don't know if they did that
back in the day probably with their
buddies and they had to be like i'm
gonna go
i'm gonna ask her to dance i'm gonna do
it they crossed that dance floor beads
of perspiration just roll i mean it was
a beautiful thing in those moments
little boys
became men gradually little by little in
the moments where
a girl got a young girl got rejected
or
anything those moments that were hard
that were rough that involved maybe you
had a conversation with someone or a
fight with a friend and you didn't
handle it so well
that built character that that that was
a little small step toward you becoming
a woman that could one day hold your
head high and sit at a microphone like
this and do this or do whatever you do
at home or
walk into your hair salon that you own
and be a boss that day
or
walk into that hair salon and do
someone's hair when they don't like it
handle that moment which we all know can
be really hard hairstylist man you got
it rough you gotta rough it's not easy
to do someone's hair when they're
displeased i'm just saying
whatever your job is in life whatever
you do you built that character from a
very young age and a lot of these kids
are not doing that now
and these people who create these video
games and create these alternate
universes they would love for you to be
weak
and first of all they want to make money
right so they need you to leave your
real life and embrace this this
metaverse
so they can make money off of the off of
all of this technology so it's a money
game
they also program a lot of these games
and social media and whatnot to get you
addicted there's there's they actually
um study behavioral psychology and they
go and study it and figure out how to
program these apps so that you'll get
addicted so you're like a puppet i'm
sure they do that with the virtual
reality games as well
so they need you addicted they need you
isolated they need you like this
they need you abandoning real life and
they need you weak why why you ask
because a population that's weak is a
population that can be controlled
a population that's disconnected from
other people is a population that can be
controlled what happened during covid
what did they do
they locked every you got to stay in
your house
you got to stay in your house you got to
isolate
had that not happen and look at places
where it didn't happen the same way like
in florida where people had a little bit
you know what they did they talked to
each other and they figured out that
none of this made any sense
they recognized the shared humanity that
they each had and they said you know
what this isn't my enemy this person
over here that got a vaccine and i
didn't this is just a person who made a
different decision
they want you control they want you to
be a puppet
a puppet and this all this ai is all
about that it's all about that and the
antidote to this is community is
interpersonal you know relationships is
eye contact it's all the hard stuff
right because all the hard stuff builds
you up as a person
so
and be and be
be not mistaken this stuff will break up
families
um it will create tension between kids
and parents when kids like are like oh
this is what's happening now this is
what i need to be doing you already see
kids
ha look at the obesity rate amongst kids
now
one of the factors of that is is that
they don't get outside i played with
like little sticks and abandoned like i
would go into like construction houses i
was a real tomboy i would climb fences i
spent almost no time in my house the
little time i did spend with nintendo
was pretty boring there wasn't a lot to
do with the nintendo back in the day
it's like super mario brothers
you went in you saw it you conquered it
it was done but what's going on here
with these virtual friends you make who
you don't know oh your kid's talking to
some virtual friend maybe it's a 60 year
old maybe he's a little weird
you don't know
you enter this world the way they want
you to enter this world you're not going
to be able to hand the handle the ups
and downs of a grocery store run you're
going to be a weak fragile
isolated coddled protected i'd rather
live in the safety of the metaverse than
the really hard real life person and
that is a perfect candidate to be
brainwashed and manipulated and
controlled so just so you know where
this is going parents
your kids want to play get them outside
you also lose connection when you're in
all this and i know we're guilty of it
too right
me i'm guilty of it i'm sure you're
guilty of it
we're all guilty of it because this is
the way of the world now you're in this
all the time you lose connection to the
ground outside you ever heard of those
people that do grounding
do you know that oh they take their they
take their shoes off right and they walk
on the grass and connect with the earth
and yep people at home do me a favor
you're by a beach you're by some grass
take your shoes off
leave this inside do me do me a favor
take your shoes off take a deep breath
put your feet on that ground if i sound
crazy to you right now so be it feel the
difference
take a break from this for two hours i
don't care what you have to do you may
be hyperventilating when i first i go
through and do not disturb by the way my
addiction to technology and i was
literally sweating i was like there
could be a message in there that's
important there wasn't
it was my mom like as i said before what
kind of tomato sauce did you get from
the store that tastes like you know
family tomatoes it was stuff like that
it'll wait it will wait
do it and tell me how you feel
okay because you need to do it
in order to realize that all this stuff
being pushed on you is poison you can do
it in moderation you can go on twitter
we show you articles here we're coming
at you live right now this is technology
this is but my perspective is not warped
and i don't want to go into a metaverse
to escape the reality of what could be a
really beautiful life with ups and downs
and lessons that build a powerful strong
human being who has self-confidence and
is out to conquer
it's not happening in the metaverse
and i'll tell you what you find your
confidence in the metaverse you take a
step back and you walk into the real
world you're gonna feel this big
because you know in your mind that it's
not real
all right
so
you know they're trying to get to the
point where they can download people's
consciousness consciousness to these uh
metaverses and and you can revisit loved
ones right if your mom passes away your
father passes away a child passes away
god forbid
so how long do you think until we get to
the point that these people enter the
metaverse to go see their mother every
day or their father every day and they
never leave and and we get to a point
almost like a social credit score where
you then cannot see those family members
unless you meet
a b and c demand right right and it's or
if even if it doesn't go that far the
fact that these people will have it in
their minds that they can though the
real life person is gone they can still
visit them in the metaverse and then
they have to leave and it's you want to
talk about a warping of reality like
right it's it's people will never be
able to cope and also think about
everyone's lost someone in their life
right people out there if you've lost a
parent
if you lost a pet if you've lost heaven
forbid a child if you've lost a loved
one a spouse whatever it may be that
grieving process is
hard
it's
painful um
it's filled with darkness at times but
you find a way
to to go through it everyone does
you walk through it you pick yourself up
hopefully you have the support of family
or friends
maybe you don't maybe you're at a point
in life where you don't and you only
have to rely on yourself
you pick yourself up and you get through
it that person that comes out on the
other side
what a warrior oh yeah it's absolutely
what a warrior
and that is the person
that
when challenged in society
by something as simple as a stupid
mandate says
i'm not doing that
i'm not doing that that's not good for
me i'm not doing that
you pull that out of some you you change
the dynamic and suddenly that person
doesn't go through that experience or
goes through it in a warped way
never gets closure never actually has to
conquer
an experience or an emotion no matter
how difficult or horrifying that may be
you take that out of the equation
you're left with a much weaker person
who doesn't feel like if the weight of
the world falls on my shoulders i'm
gonna squat and press it out
so just think about what's behind all of
this
what's behind a technology that wants
you addicted what what is that i always
think about what's the long-term goal
here
the long-term goal is to have more
people
who flock to that stuff because they're
afraid of the real world
fear is a weapon they're afraid it's
scary it's hard it's difficult it's too
challenging it's too much breakups ugh i
don't need that let me just go get a
girlfriend in the metaverse it'll be
simpler seriously
um
lasting ramifications and just if you
don't care for yourself because you say
you know what i'm not gonna do that
stuff
i'm already past that i'm past that age
where that's appealing to me i'm telling
you i want to get in a delorean and go
back to 1985. so this is not my zone but
i have a child and he's two and a half
and he's growing up in a world where let
me tell you something my kid true story
my kid doesn't use we don't have an ipad
for him
okay he has very minimal contact with tv
watch is a little bit of curious george
he loves it he thinks he's a monkey
we'll get to that we got to that late
yesterday a little bit my husband's at
home like oh there's a fun fun joke in
there jeremy i'm not telling your joke
it's not that funny on air just letting
you know anyway
my child
very rarely gets my phone when we were
driving from new york we drove here i
drove from new york to florida because i
refused to mask my two two-year-old i
was like it's not happening on an
airplane it's not happening i'm not
masking my two-year-old it's child abuse
i'm not doing it so i drove here
and in the car there were some rough
patches and a couple of times i was like
here's my phone do you know i will tell
you this child
mastered
just the photos i would put it on
airplane mode he was looking he mastered
the little like oh let me widen it let
me go here let me pick this
it was a matter of seconds and he was a
pro on this phone
i mean
way beyond me
i saw that and i said this is like
this is a lesson in like sociology this
i can't believe what's unfolding
and my husband is very opposed to kids
being around all this technology young
and he was like
but we we had to sit for a second and
just look at what had happened that
these kids they're very vulnerable to
this and that's all they see
they see you on this all the time they
see the computers they see all the
colors if you look at the cartoons
there's a reason i go back and have them
watch curious george because the
cartoons of today it's like psychedelics
it's like lights and oh my god it's like
it's too much
i'm like you want to watch a cartoon
we'll put curious george you can watch
the smurfs the old smurfs that i watched
right i told you i fancied myself
smartphone
just saying
but you can watch that you can watch mr
rogers
you're not watching this i mean it's
like remember we put on the bubble
guppies for like a couple of minutes i
was like oh no i'm out i'm out on the
guppies
so
just keep that in mind they are more
vulnerable because they also don't have
the frame of reference so
if i had a normal childhood i didn't
have a cell phone until i was in college
i had a whole youth that i had all those
experience of the high school dances and
the interpersonal contact and all of
that
so when stuff like this comes along i'm
inclined to question it i'm like
inclined to be like ugh i don't that's
not my zone i'll do a little i'm on
twitter i'll do a little but i also know
like
i can sense like this was healthy this
isn't so healthy i have i have a margin
of comparison they don't
all they see all that they're inundated
constantly constantly so just know they
are if you don't care for yourself maybe
you care for your nieces your nephews
your children
they are absorbing this stuff in a very
different way and it's it's all they see
and know
so
we want children that are strong and
independent and self-reliant who live in
the real world and play outside and
understand the beauty of sunshine and
sunsets and are able to have
conversations with someone they date one
day
that are intimate and hard and
challenging face to face
we don't want children who need to flock
to a safe space or the metaverse to
escape reality if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]